at least four people were killed in the
latest round of violence engulfing the
Middle East security is on high alert in
Bethlehem this morning as violent
clashes have erupted in the West Bank
and Israel since President Trump's
decision to recognize Jerusalem as the
Israeli capital Seth Doane is in
Jerusalem with the latest
Seth good morning good morning Israel's
Defense Forces launched airstrikes that
targeted what they claimed were four
separate military installations
belonging to Hamas Hamas is that
powerful Islamic group that controls the
Gaza Strip on display in Gaza today a
volatile mix of grief and anger in a
funeral procession for a Palestinian man
who was shot at the border with Israel
the cycle of violence is ratcheting up
this is the aftermath of an air strike
Israelis launched in retaliation for a
Hamas rocket attack across that same
border in Bethlehem today protesters
continued to melt Israeli security
forces with rocks registering their
anger with President Trump's policy
shift on Jerusalem it's a back and forth
we've also seen in the West Bank town of
Ramallah where 16 year old Shaitan
Obadiah was among the rock throwers when
you heard president Trump make that
statement what were you thinking what
went through your mind I want to kill
him seriously Israelis were expecting
violence and deployed extra battalions
of security forces though Jerusalem
mayor near Bangkok is confident mr.
Trump's decision will ultimately bring
peace it's a major important milestone
in our current future and in the future
and I thank you for that
but at what cost to security sometimes
we're threatened and sometimes people
challenge US and Israel ready to go
through all the challenges
it is often those clashes and those
protests that really grab headlines but
we've also heard a lot of much quieter
concern from people on both sides people
who run shops or run hotels Anthony they
have told us that business has been good
lately and they are concerned that all
of this violence might scare away
tourists Seth Doane in Jerusalem Thank
You Seth